is this too fast
free
special effects
hi my name is leo kelly aka the shirley
temple kings one thing that you may not
know about me is i love retro things
this is like my dream come true because
this is just my dream come true like i
said that two times well yeah just just
just cut to the first
oh
i know these these are like the
the ring thingies with the water but
they're never like the og ones
and there's so many different themes
like this one's like a basketball theme
hey i made it i made three hoops in a
row wow
i must be a skilled basketball player
it is like a game boy
except for water in it
wait i'm gonna close my eyes so i don't
know what it is now we're on toy number
two let's reach out into the mystery bag
oh
i know these these are like one of these
fidget things i thought they brought
these back
are these called like aqua tubes or
something probably not
whoa it's like jello on the inside
it just goes down it's so slippery
see what i said about it being slippery
oh my god this is the second time it's
so slippery jelly bag on to the next one
i do not want to soak this again
so jelly bags
this is exciting we are on to toy number
three
let's see what this is
it feels like velcro
oh
i know these
things i have a shield
because i usually just call them like
velcro
when i was younger i called them velcro
shields
if i were to name them
i would call them the velcro catcher
yeah the toss velcro thingy
all right
on to the next toy
oh yeah
slap bracelets i know these
i always remember winning these at like
arcades and stuff you like this one slap
it you like this one
flap it
super bracelet coming your way
let's see what's in
oh okay it feels like something in the
packaging
tech deck
i love
tech decks this is the ultimate retro
one this cannot get more retro
i should stop saying the word can we do
like a retro count how many times i've
said the word retro i love retro things
retro food
toys restaurant pizza wow that i'd
probably be at like 100 now
sometimes oh i landed it number six
mystery bag number six wow i don't even
know what this is
but this looks like something i'd like
battery repair okay
who needs rules
i do but not in this situation whoa
whoa
so i'm going to be rating these from um
the least best i don't even think lisa's
worth least best
best
sadly the
water tube
the stress tube
was not my favorite only because
it kept slipping out of my hand
my next one
is the tech deck
it's a great toy
it just really takes time
to build like there's really tiny screws
and those are choking hazards and have a
baby sister and i don't want her to get
into these
um you're not the worst to play with
they're just hard to build so that's why
i'm putting it at second worst next one
up i think these slap bracelets they're
i mean i do like slap or snap slap
bracelet man i just don't want to bring
the mess because it's kind of crazy
slap it then next
it's not my favorite it's not the best
it's not the worst anyways this one
is my second favorite
because you could play with these for
hours you could play with them on planes
trains with automobile hey that's a
great movie these are really really fun
i like the basketball one but these
rings are cool too and my favorite you
all knew it it's the magnetic wheel the
jimmy neutron
stuff let's get it started
wee
no will dude the noise is actually kind
of satisfying
metal scratching noise
really really fun
i have to give this a 10 out of 10.
these were super duper fun to play with
in review and i i never thought that i'd
see
a jelly a jello tube this is really
really quick jello trademarks never mind
this is really really fun i hope i could
do this again but maybe like go a decade
back like the 80s thank you so much crew
this is a great experience
[Music]